an attempted murder caught on video as
ring doorbell footage captures a narrow
escape the footage released by the las
vegas metropolitan police department
shows the man running across the street
as a suspect chases close behind video
then shows the man wearing a pink shirt
run toward a gate at the same time the
suspect wearing what appears to be a
white t-shirt points a gun at the man
the dramatic video shows the suspect
repeatedly pointing the gun to fire as
it jams multiple times
after trying to shoot the man at least
three times the suspect runs off
officials in nevada now ask the public
for help identifying this suspect who
they believe is a black man between 18
and 25 years old they say the incident
happened on july 24th near lake mead and
thomas w ryan boulevard in las vegas
that's where the victim returned home
and parked his car in the garage after
that the suspect approached and quote
demanded property that's when the man
ran off and the suspect followed close
behind anyone with more information
about this incident is asked to contact
crime stoppers of nevada for the latest
developments in this story and all
things true crime stay with long crime
network reporting for long crime network
i'm sierra gillespie